[Music]
we've done a lot of work on this program
to expose the bias and corruption at
Google which is the world's most
powerful company by far but Google and
its employees don't just have it out for
conservatives we want to make that clear
Google is hostile to anyone who
challenges the status quo since Google
is the chief beneficiary of the status
quo congresswoman and presidential
candidate Tulsi Gabbard learned that the
hard way just after the first
presidential debate where Gabbard was
the single most searched Democratic
candidate Google blocked her from being
able to buy new ads now she's become the
first presidential candidate to sue
Google she's accused them of censoring
her message we are happy to have
congressman Tulsi Gabbard join us
tonight congressman thanks very much for
coming on tell us the point of this suit
here's here's the bottom line this is
really about the unchecked power that
these big tech monopolies have over our
public discourse and how this is a real
threat to our freedom of speech and to
our fair election so this really isn't
about me it's about taking action on
behalf of the American people because
we've got to understand here that if
Google can do this to me
as a sitting member of Congress running
for the highest office in the land and
that means they can do this to any
candidate running for any office
anywhere in this country and frankly to
any person in this country and that's
why it's so important that whether
you're a progressive or conservative
whether you consider yourself on the
left or the right we all have to stand
united to protect our freedom of speech
because look today it's me tomorrow it
could be you or someone else yes that's
exactly right god bless you by the way
why are you the only candidate who's
saying this I can't explain that Tucker
but I do know how important it is that
we protect our freedoms in this country
it's something I think that people take
for granted unless they're the ones
under attack
these freedoms are enshrined in our
Constitution I love our country I love
our people this is why I'm standing up
and fighting for these freedoms even
when these freedoms allow those who say
things I may disagree with to have that
freedom to do so you know as a soldier
these are the principles that I stand up
for that even though you and I may
disagree on things I'm willing to give
my life for your freedom to do so
so you filed this lawsuit and god bless
you for doing that
what should lawmakers in the Congress do
to rein in this tech this dangerous tech
monopoly called Google Washington needs
to act there's no question about it
because we're talking about Google
Facebook Twitter these are big tech
monopolies that have this unchecked
power to influence our public discourse
to influence what kind of information
people are seeing Google is in control
of 88% of all internet searches in the
United States and I believe it's 92% of
all internet searches in the world so
Google is controlling when you type into
that Google search box what pops up the
information that you see so it's
important that Congress takes action
because right now this is this is
unchecked they've got their secret
algorithms they can control the
information that we see they can control
what pops up in our Facebook feeds and
they can censor voices that they
disagree with Google has spoken openly
about how they have shut out those who
have not broken any of their Terms of
Use so this is really what's at stake
here and it's important that Congress
takes action to provide this oversight
and accountability and ultimately to
break up these big tech monopolies so in
the 30 seconds we have remaining are you
gonna bring this up in the debates this
week I look forward to doing so this is
such an important important issue that
is integral to every single one of our
freedoms that we cherish and that we all
must stand up and protect it's so
important I spoke to a right-winger
today who I think disagrees with you on
virtually everything and on the basis of
this alone sent you money today because
it is it is that important this is
America this is what we're talking about
here this freedom thank you so much
Tucker amen did you see him